welcome to age 20. welcome to uh special
relativity and let me start by wishing
you all a happy new year uh happy new
year 2021 i'm pretty sure this is going
to be an exciting year with a lot of
changes ahead and a lot of exciting
events
my name is marcus schluter and i will
guide you through this iap lecture on
special relativity
this is very likely my favorite class at
mit um
a because it's iap and
we start a new year there's a lot of
excitement in the air and
um we have a chance to focus for this
one month of january
on this specific subject
b
i have a chance to introduce a man
albert einstein
through a discussion of his physics
through a discussion of him as a person
and also
through a discussion of the historic
context in which he developed special
relativity
and see
if this is the first time you encounter
special relativity it will blow your
mind and it actually is quite fun as an
instructor to you know do a little bit
of a transformation a new understanding
on on physics so let's get started
um with a quote with an einstein quote i
have a number of those
as we go through the class
this one here is really you know kind of
the theme of the class
um let me just read this to you
it is not the result of scientific
research that enables humans and
enriches their nature but the struggle
to understand while performing creative
and open-minded intellectual work
it is really you know the struggle with
the ideas really the trying to get
understanding which ennobles humans and
enriches their natures and let me add
here um
that through your own work um so your
own mind you can transform yourself
in your understanding of physics in
general
this first video and this first lecture
will mostly be concerned with
organizational
topics so i'll lay out
the schedule of the class and also how
you get a grade or what kind of presets
we have in mind and so on
let's get started so i introduced myself
already again marcus cluter you can
reach me by email at clutter mit.edu we
have a graduate ta justin his email is
given on the slide as well and then we
have two
graders and tas mohit zak
and steven
those four
will guide us through the class as well
and especially when we go into breakout
rooms in the live class they will help
you
in the discussion the class hours are
from 3 to 4 30 p.m on zoom
um
and you can you know i encourage you to
to join the class to
participate to be active in the class
but you will also be able to get to the
material through recordings i will not
record the live class because i want to
encourage you to be just as open as
possible but i pre-record the class and
after the class time is over i'll upload
those uh videos um for your for your
reference and also if you live in a
different time zone you have a chance to
listen to the class
office hours will be tuesday at 9 00 a.m
and friday at 5am tuesday you reach me
and friday you reach justin
we will set up a slack workspace which
uh we use for our internal discussions
um with the teaching staff but um
there's also going to be channels for
you to discuss psets there's channels we
discuss the physics
and there's going to be a channel which
will be important when we go to the to
the exam discussion
the expectation is that you spend about
30 hours a week during iip
some will find the presets very
straightforward and quickly to do others
will need more time so it's just it's
not a you know don't set your stopwatch
for 30 hours that's just an average
guide
um i will evaluate you at the end of the
term um
and i will use this this metric here 50
of your grade will come from the
homework there's going to be five
different homework assignments there's
going to be two midterms with 15 each
and one final with 20
if i do the mass correctly this should
lead us to a hundred percent
uh you earn an a with 90 percent b with
75 percent i see the 60 percent or
higher a d is 50 or higher and a failing
grade is less than 50
so all lectures will be on zoom
you find the zoom links on the canvas
page and
you probably found this already
otherwise you wouldn't be able to find
this video and again as i was saying the
recordings will be available after class
this is the schedule um let me start by
uh explaining this picture there's a
little thomas here and then a german ice
train um this class
the way i look at this class is
a train which is just leaving the
station right now and it will you know
very slowly pick up space
um pace
um but
you want to make sure that you stay on
the train and you don't jump off because
you know if this will one once it's
picked up its pace will be a fast moving
train
and uh missing a few days in iap
uh will cause you to have trouble
following along with the material
um we'll start today with this
introduction um tomorrow we have a very
interesting
uh lecture by david kaiser this is the
only one where we actually record the
live live event so we will record the
zoom session
um and then the rest will unfold i was
also saying you find this red block here
those are our midterms and the final
on those days there's not going to be a
live class
but i will make the a final sorry the
exam available
for about 24 hours
you should not spend more than an hour
maybe an hour and a half on on on the
exam and then submit once you're done
the
the exams are um
open book in a sense that you can look
at the textbooks and you can look at the
course material
but you are not supposed to you know do
an online search for the solutions and
you're also not supposed to discuss with
your
peers you can ask the clarifying
question on one of the slack channels
and we will be happy to answer as
quickly as we see them
but again this is an evaluation of your
own performance and you should submit
your own performance
the psets are different in a sense that
i encourage that you guys you know build
small groups and work on them together
um
each pset then has to be submitted by
you as an individual
meaning that i don't want to see copies
of presets of other folks i want your
own answers in your own words to the
questions
um very important day in in january is
martin luther
gives us all a little bit of a breathing
room an extra free day
and you see that you know there's going
to be
um after the discussion at the very end
after the final a special lecture where
i introduced the topic of general
relativity um which is not par part of
the core
content of especially of this special
relativity class
textbooks um i will not really follow
the textbooks line by line or chapter by
chapter but i encourage you and i give
you an outline and to read them
especially the first two one first one
is by french the second one is by
resnick
the former the first one is a former mit
professor
you are supposed to read this book cover
to cover and i give reading assignments
on this
resnick has a lot of good examples and
problems and we will focus on the first
four chapters of that book
there is a lot of literature i would say
on special relativity as a
slew of textbooks available if you have
one at hand you can also use that and
find the relevant chapter in there
um i give you one extra book here which
is nice because it is
an excellent
explanation of the mathematics involved
if you're more inclined
to course course 18 that might be an
interesting textbook for you
again there's many many resources on the
topic of special relativity and i've
pointed out a few as we go
in addition to the textbooks i give you
a number of papers for example the paper
in which einstein explains
what describes the concept of the theory
of special relativity
and there's a few others which i'd like
you to read they're interesting because
they
they introduce the physics but they're
also interesting as they have been
written more than 100 years ago in a
slightly different language than we
would be using today and
einstein specifically doesn't even write
papers the way other people wrote papers
at the time
he had his own style on the writing
papers and we will see that
so here's a reading assignment week by
week
you know we start in week one by resnick
chapter one french chapter two there's
two papers the michelson-morley paper
and the einstein paper on special
relativity and then we go on
as we go through iap
the homework schedule is here
i hand out pset number zero today
and i'll explain it on the next page
this
is a pset which allows i mean this is a
preset which will keep you busy uh for
the entire month or most of it on the
other psets are
shorter
and they are more pointed and you know
you get the pset you work on it and you
hand in the solution and by the time you
have done that the next piece rolls
around
i would use the pset load a little bit
because i want to acknowledge the fact
that it will be harder for you to work
in teams i still encourage this uh you
find yourself on slack you find yourself
on zoom channel some of you might have
housing together
um i really encourage you guys to
discuss the physics there are some
really
difficult concepts
um which just need you to
think through and to talk through and
the talking through best happens with
your peers and you will see that that
will be very beneficial especially when
it comes to the pset
so here's homework number one um i've
done this now a few times and i really
really enjoy
the
solutions given by the students
um so this is a creative project um
you know you have basically almost all
of irp to hand it in and the idea is to
be creative around
a topic relating einstein
or and the special
the
serial of special relativity
the project might be a video it might be
a poem it might be a musical piece
artwork animations
a game
a structure
you name it
what i really want is that you take
something you do very well
and combine it
with the topic of this class um i want
you to
take something where you are very
familiar with
where you are feeling comfortable
and then enter this new topic this new
topic of special relativity
i will
rate it based on your creativity on the
quality and on your effort
and again this sends this in by january
22nd i really encourage you to not wait
to the last minute to start working on
that those topics those creative
projects they always take a little bit
more time than you might expect
this class will have
an interactive component and
we will use breakout rooms for
discussions and
smaller programs programs as you would
be doing in the classroom as well
here is the very first one um
what people who are taking this class
asynchronously i encourage you to stop
here and
work through the problem
and then look at the solution afterwards
or look at the discussion of the
solution afterwards so this first duncan
experiment thought experiment
is about the topic of relativity
and
you know
[Music]
you
you want to first understand what that
is before you do
for what relativity is before you
discuss what a special relativity is
so imagine
you wake up inside a room with no
windows
and
one locked door you checked you make
sure that the door is locked you cannot
get out you cannot see outside looking
out around you see a table with a number
of items on it there's a desk lamp
plugged in and turned on as a tennis
ball
there's a bunch of string
there's a picture of water there's a cup
there's a candle there's a box of
matches and there's a music player with
headphones
a skateboard and a wooden stool are also
in the room the music player has a sign
on it saying turn it on for instructions
so you do
you're told that you're in a special
specially designed vibration proof and
noise proof train car
sorry
on a set of straight and level train
tracks
your task is to use one or more of the
items in the room
perhaps in combination with each other
to determine whether the train car is
stationary or is moving on the tracks
there's a 30 minute time limit on your
test
or tests
and
you cannot destroy or you cannot modify
the walls or the floors or the seating
of the car
that is not permitted
um so the question to you is can you
think of some creative way
to use the items that might indicate
whether or not you're moving
think about this and discuss your
breakout rooms
that is for the live session here again
i want to encourage you to stop
and to think about
a solution can you think about a
creative way
to work with this
the typical time is about 10 minutes you
might want to think about it you might
want to take some notes
all right
the answer is you cannot figure it out
every reference frame by itself
um
is
is
[Music]
inert you cannot figure out whether or
not you're in a moving or in a in a
stationary reference frame and as long
as you cannot feel vibrations or you
hear the sound or you have some other
internal external indication you will
not be able to figure out whether or not
the room is moving with a constant
velocity
you will be able to feel
or measure accelerations
and so now you could argue that you know
since the train track is on earth and
the earth
is actually
uh since since you're on on earth and if
you're moving you would
be able to feel
the rotation of the earth there might be
a way to figure this out um but that
will be very very hard to do
so the answer is you cannot you cannot
distinguish one reference frame from
another you don't know what an absolute
velocity is
so another way we will interact in this
class is the concept questions so here
concept questions are meant to you know
give you a little bit of a checkpoint to
encourage you to think about what i just
explained in a video or in the class and
to stimulate some sort of discussion
sometimes you will use concept questions
in breakout rooms for the discussion
part
sometimes we'll just use room features
in order to figure out what
the answer is but besides the technology
those concept questions are really for
you
to figure out whether or not you did
just understand the concept
um so again i encourage you to
you know
pause the video to think about the
concept question and then move on with
the answer
here's an example
um
[Music]
a new star wars movie came out
2019
and i asked you to pick the answer
closest to your level of starburst
servers expertise
i saw the movie and consider myself a
star wars fan i saw the new movie but i
do not know much about star wars i heard
about star wars but i didn't see the
movie yet always liked star trek better
what star wars
okay so
very straightforward here i would give
you an option one two three or four we
collect the answers and we get some
feedback this is obviously there's no
right answer here
there can be concept questions where
there is a right and the wrong answer
and again for you this is supposed to
give you feedback
on how well you understood the concept
all right before we close this first
video i want to introduce players um
alice and bob we will have um
often discussions of reference frames
typically alice or bob are in one
reference frame and then the other
person is in the other reference frame i
want you to think about those star trek
um figures um we will use
spacecrafts we will use light
so phasers or light
pistols
in order to
demonstrate the impact of special
relativity you understand understand the
concepts
you